on aurait aimé qu'il fasse du combat
contre le chômage du combat contre
l'insécurité du combat pour réformer
notre modèle économique est l'un de ses
derniers combats pas plus qu'il n'a été
capable de le faire
ces dernières années il ne sera capable
de le faire les prochains mois
évidemment il est assez scandaleux de
voir que le président la république n'a
rien d'autre à faire que d'utiliser les
moyens de l'état d'ailleurs pour faire
campagne contre fait campagne qui
représente plusieurs millions
d'électeurs il fait campagne contre vous
bah écoutez en tout cas c'est lui qu'ils
annoncent donc nous attendons de voir
enfin très honnêtement si monsieur
hollande fait campagne contre nous je
pense que c'est à prendre comme un bon
signe parce que ça veut dire qu'on
s'oppose à sa politique que donc nous
sommes sur la bonne voie